will be divided into two parts so there
will be
25 minutes of talk and then a 10-minute
break
and then another 25 minutes um
and during the talk if you have any
questions just like before
you can feel free to put your questions
in the chat
um either publicly or you can also like
privately message them to me if you want
them to be anonymous
um in particular i just want to mention
that like questions we
really strongly encourage questions from
students because bad math day is meant
to be for you
um so there's no bad questions um
and yeah so feel free to ask any
questions that you have in the chat
um and i guess yeah i think i think we
can get started now
um so yes only bad math questions
thank you max um
so our next speaker will be nikhil
srivastava from uc berkeley
and he'll be telling us about a spectral
approach to polytope diameter
so whenever you're ready thanks a lot
marielle and thanks very much to the
organizers
for inviting me it's my first bad math
day it's also my first time talking
about this work
uh so this is a joint work with
hariharan narayanan who's at tifr
mumbai and rickoff shah who's a student
at uc berkeley
and it's a talk relating discrete
geometry
uh spectral graph theory and um
i guess convex geometry um and
the talk will be divided into three
parts so first i'll set up the problem
i'm interested in which is
diameter of polytopes which is a
combinatorics problem
then i'll tell you about the technique
from spectral graph theory that we use
to attack this problem
then we'll have a break and then i'll
tell you how we
use some ideas from convex geometry to
put these two things together
so the talk is about polytopes so
what's a polytope so i'm going to
consider
a set p a subset of r rd
which is defined by linear inequalities
so it's a set of vectors x so that ax is
less than or equal to b
and i'm going to assume b is strictly
positive so in particular this implies
that the origin is contained in the set
and you know assuming the set is bounded
this is a convex polytope
containing the origin
so the two important parameters in the
stock are going to be the dimension d
and the number of constraints m which is
the number of rows of the matrix a which
is an m by d matrix
so given such a polytope
we can study its combinatorial structure
and
one of the most you know basic ways to
do that is to look at its vertices and
edges
so i'm going to define a point on the
boundary of the polytope to be a vertex
if some d constraints are tight at that
point
and um i'm going to define a maximal
line cycle a line segment containing the
boundary to be an edge if some d minus
one constraints are tied on the line
segment and now required to be a maximal
line segment
so in this so here's an example of a
polytope it's just the unit cube
uh the constraints are just plus minus
the standard basis vectors
uh so you know i've written previously i
wrote it as ax less than or equal to b
but you can also just write it as the
set of x so that x
inner product aj is less than or equal
to b j for some constraints for some
vectors aj that are the rows of a so in
this case those are just plus or minus
the standard basis vectors uh the
vertices so i've plotted
you know cube in three dimensions the
vertices are just okay
so the dots and the edges are the lines
containing these dots
so those are any questions about the
these basic definitions of a polytope a
vertex
or an edge
okay so are we assuming
sorry are we assuming that the
description ax
less than equal to b is like as like
optimal as it can be as in like there
are no redundant
rows um no
sure let's assume that yeah okay yeah
you're right let's assume that otherwise
the d constraints
wouldn't make sense okay yeah let's
assume there are no redundant rows
thanks um
okay uh so so given a polytope
in particular what this means is you
have these vertices and edges
but these now define an undirected graph
right so if you just view the vertices
as vertices of graph and the edges as
just
you know pairs of vertices you get an
undirected graph that i'm going to call
g sub p
which is the one skeleton of this
polytube
and what we're going to be interested in
is this one skeleton
so um so so so the number of vertices of
this one skeleton is the number of
vertices of the polypeptide
so the main question we're interested in
is this
given a polytope in d dimensions with m
constraints that are not redundant
how large can the diameter of the one
skeleton possibly be
so by diameter i mean in the sense of
graph diameter so the
maximum shortest path between two
vertices in the graph
gp how large can this be as a function
of m and d
and this is motivated by linear
programming where if you run the simplex
algorithm
you want to you know maximize some
linear function on a polytope
you move along this one skeleton and the
number of steps is bounded
it was related to this number the
diameter
and so this picture here this is some
polytope and
you know i've i've drawn uh or i stole
this picture from daniel derose who has
you know drawn its skeleton and
you know in the simplex algorithm we're
taking a walk along the skeleton and so
this is what's shown here is some path
between two vertices in the skeleton
we want to understand how long these can
possibly be
so there's a trivial bound uh which is
well the diameter is at most
m choose d because that's the trivial
upper bound on the number of vertices
and that's exponential in d so that's a
very large bound
it's not it's not very useful but that's
sort of
you know some bound to give you some
idea of what kind of numbers we're going
to
look at and so
okay so this is the question and this is
an old question
going back to at least the 50s and a
guiding question in this area is the
famous conjecture of hersh from 1957
which is actually the diameter should be
much smaller than the number of vertices
so the the what used to be called the
hurst conjecture
is that the diameter of the of gp this
one skeleton
is at most m minus d where m is the
number of constraints and d
is the um dimension of the polytope
so this was well open for a very long
time
and there are many results about it i'll
just say some of
some of the landmark results so one
important result is the theorem of kali
and klitman from 1992
who proved that the diameter is at most
m minus d to the log d
okay so that's much better than m to the
d which was the trivial bound we saw
earlier
it's also much worse than m minus d it's
not polynomial in d
uh it's uh you know i mean
it's it's it's not it's not a polynomial
in m d right it's m to the log d
quasi polynomial um
this is a beautiful paper by the way
this proof is like less than a page long
i highly encourage
anyone who hasn't seen it to look at it
and i should say that over the decades
there were some
small improvements to this result or to
this
lightman result but this essentially
this is the ballpark best that
is known for general polytopes nothing
better than this is known even though
so there's a big gap between the upper
and lower bounds uh
i mean well or between the conductor
upper bound and the known upper bound
and another very important result is
this
famous result of santos from 2012 where
he disproved the
hurst conjecture so he he proved
um the following that there's some
constant epsilon and an infinite family
of polytopes with dimension going to
infinity
such that the diameters of their
skeletal are at least one plus epsilon
times m
okay so this disproves m
minus d right um but it's still it's
still very far from
this upper bound right the lower bound
is linear the upper bound is quasi-polar
wheel
and so and this picture that's shown
here these are the
bad polytopes that santos constructed
they're called spindles
and the feature that they have that's
kind of counter-intuitive is somehow
using
not too many constraints you're able to
define lots of tiny edges
and that blows up the diameter of the
skeleton
so these are sort of the highlights of
what's known about this problem in the
worst case
and it's still what's what's now you
know the sort of guiding conjecture in
this field is what's called the
polynomial hirsch conjecture written
below
which is that well can you just prove
that the diameter is some polynomial in
m and d
some fixed polynomial and that's not
that's still open
so any questions about this summary of
the
status of this conjecture
i have a question um so
are there from the picture it looks like
there's already counter examples in
dimension three is that right
okay so you don't have to like go ahead
well okay so this picture
is a is a i think a projection of
the smallest counter example which is in
dimension five
ah okay and what santos does in his
paper is
a lot of the work is finding this
counter example in dimension five which
i think has 43 constraints or something
like that
but then there's some like inductive way
to boost that into an infinite family
so really indeed the core is to find
this example in dimension five
so i don't actually know exactly what
this picture is this is a picture in
dimension three
and it probably doesn't violate the
horse connector because the hurst
connector is true in dimensions
but it's supposed to convey the idea of
the construction
i see thanks so is the conjecture true
in dimension 4 but it's not in
five or above uh i think so i don't know
i think many some people in the audience
may know better than me it is true in
dimension three i don't know if it's i
don't know what the status of dimension
four is
does anybody know
okay so that's that's the general horse
conjecture
and this is still quite
open um oh somebody's saying they
thought the counter example was 43
dimensional
um okay you're probably right uh
i said 43 was the number of constraints
maybe that's the dimension uh
yeah it's some constant dimensional
example
okay 43 dimensional 86 facet my mistake
uh
in that case i don't know is the hurst
conjecture true in dimension five
does anybody know
oh okay so i take it back it is true in
dimension five
um maybe known up to dimension six uh is
what
somebody is saying in the chat so yeah
thanks a lot
um okay but any
the general asymptotic version is this
is what's known
uh okay so before i tell you the results
i want to
mention another line of work which is to
study a slightly easier problem
which is given a polytope now specified
with an integer matrix of constraints so
a is now a now it's integer entries and
so does b
the question is can you prove a bound on
the diameter of the skeleton of the
polytope in terms of the dimension the
number of constraints
and um uh and
this parameter delta which depends on
the size of the integers appearing in
the description of the polytope
and so it turns out it's natural to use
delta being the maximum
determinant of a sub matrix of a
okay so this is a measure of how big are
the numbers being used to define the
polytope
and this this is sort of an easier
question right that if i also tell you
that these numbers are
kind of small can you prove a bound on
the diameter of the polytube
and uh the first result in this line was
due to dire and freeze
from 1994 and they showed that if this
delta is one
so which means the matrix is unimodular
then indeed
the polynomial type bound is true the
diameter is a some polynomial in m
and d i think it's raised to the 13 or
something like that
so a fix it's a very explicit number
and then there are several intermediate
works and the latest result in this
line is this result of deduction handler
who proved that the diameter of a
polytube is actually
at most d cubed times this delta squared
so if you have a polytope which is
defined using a matrix whose
determinants are all small
then the diameter has to be small d
cubed times delta squared
and the result i'm going to talk about
today is a slight improvement of this it
says
the same under the same assumptions you
get a bound of d squared delta squared
times some log factor
okay now this is not supposed to be a
big deal this
the result itself is slightly better
than the previous results
the reason i want to talk about it is
that it uses a new technique
which gives a very simple proof of this
result
and i really wanted to give the simplest
consequence of that technique so i'm
going to talk about this here
so any questions about yeah i have a
question um
so the determinant like this like
i'm assuming s and p can vary in size
right correct like from one to
the whole thing uh so why does it make
sense to look at determinants of
different major i mean they
feel like they have different units so
you're taking max over different things
uh yeah you have different units you're
absolutely right this is just sort of an
artifact of how the literature
evolved because it people are interested
in unimodular matrices because
determinant being one actually means
something
that the inverse is integral and then
somehow that just became uh i mean they
chose to parameterize the problem this
way
really the only thing that matters is
the
maximum entries uh the the maximum
one by one minors which are the entries
and the maximum n minus one by uh sorry
uh
m yeah uh d minus one by d minus one
minor
so okay really you're right that this is
this quantity is really capturing a
couple of different quantities
i see yeah so so if you just know these
two quantities like you just come like
you have two two numbers just comparing
the one
times one and the minus one times n
minus one uh
would you get sharper results yeah this
delta squared is really delta
one times delta like d minus one i see
yeah
okay sounds good okay so that's a
statement of the theorem so any
questions about the statement
any more questions
i'm sorry whenever i said n i should
have said d d is a dimension yeah
okay so we're going to prove this
theorem using a
sort of nice observation in spectral
graph theory so let me tell you
what that is so spectral graph theory is
when you study graphs by
doing linear algebra with the with their
adjacency matrices
and what i'm going to use in this talk
is a slightly generalized notion called
a generalized adjacency matrix so if you
have a graph g
on n vertices then a symmetric matrix
metric real matrix is going to be called
a generalized adjacency matrix of the
graph
if for any off-diagonal entry sij it's
non-zero
if and only if there's an edge in the
graph
okay so in the usual adjacency matrix
you put one if there's an edge in the
graph and this one you're allowed to put
anything
but it must be symmetric and we don't
care about the diagonals so that's a
generalized adjacency matrix
and i'm going to prove a little theorem
which i'm going to call theorem
s as for spectral which relates the
spectrum of any generalized adjacency
matrix
to the diameter of the graph the
combinatorial diameter of the graph
okay so here is the
statement of the theorem so suppose you
have a generalized adjacency matrix
s for a graph g
and suppose one of its eigenvalues is
equal to one plus gamma
where gamma is positive and all the
other eigenvalues are contained in the
unit interval
so of course the eigenvalues are real
because it's symmetric and so the
picture is shown at the bottom of the
slide
i have the real line lambda one is one
plus gamma
and then everybody all the other
eigenvalues are sitting in this interval
minus one to one
that's the assumption that you have a
graph whose generalized daisy matrix has
this property
so this is called a spectral gap the gap
between the largest eigenvalue and the
next one
then the claim is the diameter of the
graph is bounded by log of the number of
vertices
plus twice log of 1 over v min
so v min is the minimum absolute value
of an entry of the eigenvector
corresponding to this top eigenvalue
okay so right all the eigenvalues have
some real eigenvectors
i'm going to look at the one
corresponding to the special eigenvalue
lambda 1 and
look at the minimum absolute value
of one of its entries so then the claim
is the diameter is that must log in
plus 2 log 1 over v min over square or
gamma which where gamma is a spectral
gap
so what this is saying is if you have if
you find a generalized adjacency matrix
with a large spectral gap
and somehow managed to control its top
eigenvector you will get a diameter
bound
sorry v min is taking a defined using
the sine
or not absolute value absolute value
minimum absolute
value okay so so in particular if one of
the entries is zero this doesn't give
anything yeah you need the top
eigenvector to have all non-zero entries
for this to be
not vacuous well i can always scale the
eigenvector right so
what do you mean you unit unit vector
sorry
unit vector yeah yeah okay so
minimum absolute value of an entry of v
one after it's scaled to be a unit
vector
okay and and i should say this is not
really a new theorem i mean
this is proven by fan chung in the 80s
for adjacency matrices and generalized
by
uh van damme and hamer is in 95 for a
slightly larger class
and essentially the same proof but i'm
just stating it this way
it works in this uh this setting of
generalization c matrices
so any questions about the statement of
theorem s
okay so i'm going to tell you the proof
of theorematics
so this is the statement of the theorem
the proof is one slide okay so
prove the same the statement is you have
this generalization matrix with a
spectral gap
so the spectrum looks as shown here and
you want to bound on the diameter so
what's the proof
well okay uh
wait a minute um yeah so the first step
is to look at
s to the k for some integer k right so
you raise this
generalization matrix to the k and let's
say you've diagonalized it so the
eigenvalues are lambda 1 through lambda
n
with corresponding unit eigenvectors
which is important
v1 through vn so i've written it in this
form so by the spectral theorem
s to the k sorry there should be a to
the k here
s to the k is lambda 1 to the k times v
1 v 1 transpose plus
the same thing over the other
eigenvalues
okay and now i'm going to use
the spectral gap right so the spectral
gap tells me that all the lambda
i's that are not equal to one are
bounded by one
and lambda one is one plus gamma right
so that means
entry wise this matrix is bigger
than 1 plus gamma to the k times v1 v1
transpose
minus n times the all ones matrix okay
so what what facts am i using here i'm
using that
the eigenvectors are normalized so all
their entries are bounded by one
right so this v1 v1 transpose all the
entries are bounded by one
so i define j to be the ones matrix
and then uh you know this uh i get that
they're all bounded by j
and on the other hand v one i know its
least entry is at least v min right
so all of the entries of v one and v one
transpose are lower bounded by v min
squared times saw one's matrix
and so i get this entry wise bound that
this s sub k is at least one plus gamma
to the k
times this v min squared times always
matrix minus n times all one's matrix
so any questions so far
okay but now the point is that this is
strictly positive for every entry
if one plus gamma to the k times v n
squared is strictly bigger than n
right because the first term dominates
in every entry
so in particular that means when k is
log n plus log of one over v n squared
over
gamma this is this whole matrix is
strictly positive
every entry is positive
so i've what i've discovered is that
there's a somewhat low power
of the generalized adjacency matrix
which has strictly positive entries
and now i'm done right because well if
the i j entry of s to the k is zero not
zero that means the distance between i
and j and the graph is at most g
that's where i use that it's an
adjacency matrix right all the only
non-zero entries correspond
to edges so if s to the k the i j
entry is not zero it means there's a
path of length k between i and j
so this gives me the diameter bound the
diameter is bounded by this log n
plus log one over v n squared over gamma
that's not what's written in the
statement of the theorem but any
questions about what i just proved
so it seems like you're taking uh the
first that you take
can be quite loose uh but i guess you
can compensate it by raising k
to a larger power so exactly this is
general
excuse me so so like taking all together
how
how tight or how loose is this bound i
mean this this can be this can be very
loose um you know i mean
it really depends on how well that
eigenvector is
yeah you know i mean you have graphs
where v min is exponentially small so
you can get very bad bounce in this
yeah yeah
so so i should say though this doesn't
prove the theorem right the theorem has
a square
gamma this has a gamma right
but the conceptual point is uh this
spectral gap allows you to prove that a
low power has all positive entries
now how do you get the square root gamma
while you do the sort of standard thing
you replace s to the k by a chebyshev
polynomial applied to s
okay so a championship polynomial is you
know this orthogonal polynomial
that maybe we all know dk of cosine
theta is cosine of k
theta it has a property that's bounded
in the unit interval by one
by the formula written because it's a
cosine and it blows up very rapidly
outside this interval
so if you replace the polynomial x to
the k by chebyshev everywhere here
and the same proof works actually right
because the spectral
mapping still works so tk of s is tk of
lambda 1
plus you know summation over tk of
lambda i blah blah blah
you get the same thing but you pick up a
square root because this blows up faster
than a monomial
so you literally get the same theorem
with the square root
right because now i've exhibited again a
polynomial of s
which is everywhere non-zero but then
the diameter is bounded by the degree of
that polynomial
so that's the proof of theorem s so any
questions about the proof of theorem s
nickel can i ask is the are you
using somehow that the entries of this
first
eigenvector v1 are non-negative when you
do this first inequality
uh yes okay you're right um you're right
okay
uh that's a good point um
i am using that okay so yeah i should
throw in one more assumption that all
the off-diagonal entries have the same
sign
uh thank you yeah so so um so i should
uh you're right so i used in this proof
that v1 v1 transpose is bigger entry
wise than vmin squared times
a and for that i would need all the
entries of v1 to have the same sign
and so the you're right i should add one
more assumption to this theorem
which is that all the off diagonal
entries are the same sign and then by
parent for benious v one
is positive and it works thank you yeah
i see thanks
and yeah of course there should be a to
the k you know i mean yeah okay but yeah
any more questions about this so is the
distance
between the two vertices the same thing
as the diameter
like the minimum of the uh right
that's right because in this bottom
statement we're proving that
for all i and j the distance is bounded
by k right
for every pair i and j so that means the
maximum distance is bounded by
k in this case oh so diameter is the
max oh okay yeah oh yeah yeah so i
should maybe i should define it this is
the maximum
over vertices i and j in the graph
of the distance in the graph between i
and j sorry maybe i should have
explicitly defined it that's the graph
diameter
and here i've proved that for every
right for every i and j
in the graph this happens so therefore
the graph diameter is bounded by k
okay thanks yep
uh how do you go from tk of s having
non-zero entries to
to distance less than equal to k because
in the power case it's very clear but
now you have cancellation possibly
uh right so you may you may have
cancellations but you can never create
entries between a pair of vertices
that that's a distance greater than uh
sorry uh if you if you have a polynomial
of degree k right
then it is still true that every
non-zero every non-zero entry
in tk of s comes from a path of length
at most k
so cancellations will only create zeros
right they'll never create non-zeros
any more questions that's the end of the
first part of the talk by the way so
the next part i'll use this to say
something about polytubes
[Music]
so if there's no more questions right
now why don't we take our stretch break
so we'll come back
at um should i have to convert